young man has gunned down in his north
las vegas neighborhood now one week
later there have been no arrests it
happened on boulder bay street near lone
mountain and north fifth street tonight
the parents of the victim sat down with
our own victoria saha
on the morning of march 18th 25 year old
victor lee boardley was supposed to be
walking home from work i say where is my
son i hope he's with a friend spending a
night with a friend and he okay north
las vegas police got a call saying a man
in his 20's was found shot on the
sidewalk as soon as paramedics arrived
he died the quiet neighborhood of
boulder bay street was blocked off for
hours as police searched for any clues
that could lead them to a suspect i seen
it on the news
and i was telling somebody man that's in
my neighborhood
i didn't know it was my son
victor lee was just 10 minutes from his
house after not hearing from him all day
the board leaves got a call no one ever
wants to get it said clark county corner
on the phone
the caller id
and my heart just sank the board leads
say they were told victor was shot once
in the chest they are confident it was
not a random shooting if you all got
into a situation where you always
confronting each other why not just use
this a son lost but never forgotten as
victor lee leaves behind a baby boy who
is the spitting image of him she's never
walking through my door again victoria
saha live local now